it's hard to believe but it was 25 years
ago mrs. Robinson sedusa daughter's
fiance Benjamin and nobody lived happily
ever after except the stars of the
Graduate and here they are tonight from
New York and the East Coast Oscar party
Academy Award winners Dustin Hoffman and
Anne Bancroft
a quaint notion persists even today but
as writers women are best at the
relationship thing while they are
between a naturalist and a gorilla
between a boy and an extraterrestrial
and between two women and a green tomato
its pleasant to report that another
woman joins her sisterhood with one of
this year's nominations for Best
Screenplay based on material previously
produced or published thank you these
nominations are Peeta bonds for
enchanted April based on the novel by
elisabeth von Arnim Luke's father Joe
Bala for Howards End based on a novel by
EM Forster Michael chosen for the player
based on his novel mr. friedenberg for a
river runs through it based upon the
story by Norman MacLean Oh Goldman for a
scent of a woman
based on the previous film Profumo d
dona by yuujiro Macari and Dino Lisi and
the novel Evo al PLA by Giovanni our
Pinot
we're going to do this Ruth plower Jolla
for Howard
I mean she well she couldn't be here so
we on behalf of the Academy we
congratulate her and we accept on her
behalf
there is another category for riders and
this is for the best screenplay written
directly for the screen and not
previously published or produced thank
you are you trying to seduce me not
anymore
oh we haven't done those nominations are
Neil Jordan for The Crying Game
Woody Allen for husbands and wanted
George Miller Nick Enright for Lorenzo's
oil John Sayles for passion fish david
webb people for Unforgiven and the Oscar
goes to Neil Jordan for the client
thank you
thank you sorry I didn't know these
nominations were coming up I was in the
bathroom when I heard her but to look
thank you very much it was a difficult
to write people said to me it was about
characters that were unappealing and
would be unappealing to audience at
large but I think the way audiences have
responded to this film has told me
anyway that audiences have it in their
hearts to embrace any range of
characters in any range of points of
view can I thank Stephen Wadley my
producer over there the cast included
the myth of the movie em Moran including
miranda Richardson Steven Rae and Brenda
Ron my partner and my assistant and my
mother and sister sitting over there
thank you very much Rita for Diane
Keaton and Sir Anthony Hopkins
on Oscar night